[Música]
el mayor Puerto comercial de túnez en
los locales de la marina mercante el
director del puerto nos muestra con
orgullo las pantallas de control que
permiten vigilar el inmenso complejo
portuario
hemos instalado 137 cámaras en el puerto
en los muelles que reciben los
contenedores Y en el otro muelle que
recibe los productos a granel
hace unos meses este nuevo sistema
permitió bloquear un camión que
transportaba droga
esta operación parece banal pero
facilitó muchas detenciones Y tuvo
consecuencias importantes
estos productos Podrían haber pasado por
el puerto de rades y haberse extendido
por todo el territorio
tiene una reputación deplorable los
políticos llevan años prometiendo acabar
con la corrupción y los bloqueos que lo
asolan
en los muelles camiones y equipos de
manipulación van y vienen sin parar para
descargar organizar almacenar sin
embargo en términos de rendimiento
graves es uno de los puertos con la peor
clasificación en el mundo
tenemos una producción de siete
contenedores por ahora y esperamos
llegar a 12
un objetivo de 12 contenedores por hora
que parece bastante humilde los puertos
de la Cuenca del Mediterráneo que tienen
el mismo tamaño manipulan una media de
35 contenedores por hora aquí los barcos
a veces permanecen en altamar varias
semanas antes de poder descargar su
mercancía
a menudo se señala a las empresas
tunecina estibadora por sus deficiencias
[Música]
esta empresa que realiza operaciones de
manipulación Disfruta de una situación
de cuasi monopolio en los puertos del
país
con nuestras máquinas tenemos los medios
para almacenar y apilar los contenedores
Y colocarlos de forma que haya poco
espacio entre las puertas
el sistema que ve detrás de mí deja poco
espacio entre las puertas y por tanto
evita los robos
[Música]
pero no son siempre las mercancías
robadas las que más afectan el
rendimiento del puerto según una
encuesta de 2020 para los tunecinos la
corrupción Es sobre todo el soborno que
se paga para acelerar o facilitar un
trámite para resolver un asunto en la
administración un exministro habló sin
tapujos en la radio pública sobre este
tipo de prácticas conocemos las tarifas
son 100 binarias para recuperar y evitar
las esperas en el camión en 2020 el
ministro de transporte o las pérdidas
del puerto de rade en un billón de
dinares es decir varios cientos de
millones de euros
desde estas declaraciones el portavoz de
aduanas quiere creer que las nuevas
herramientas digitales reducirán la
corrupción
las nuevas herramientas digitales ayudan
a reducir la corrupción y la posibilidad
de la corrupción
Este es el camino que han tomado las
aduanas desde 2018
las nuevas tecnologías permiten una
mayor trazabilidad en todos los
procedimientos aduaneros
Se presenta como un denunciante
fue despedido del servicio de aduanas
tras 21 años de trabajo
en su página de Facebook denuncia
regularmente los abusos que se cometen
en su antiguo administración
la corrupción en túnez no es tan
necesariamente vinculada a los
funcionarios de la administración
son las empresas los comerciantes Los
que buscan regularizarlo más rápido
posible la situación de sus mercancías
buscarán la solución más eficaz pagando
un soborno para evitar el papeleo y los
procedimientos complicados
ha hecho de la lucha contra la
corrupción una de sus prioridades
ha prometido combatir las malas
prácticas en el ámbito político y
empresarial
pero también la corrupción cotidiana que
pese a las promesas del presidente
elegido en 2019 sigue envenenando la
vida de los tunecinos
[Música]